So when a program generates
a virtual address, for
example, does a load or a store to it.
The processor needs to access
some physical address.
The question is how does the map
what the program is trying to
access to what really
should be accessed?
This mapping would be really hard,
if every byte of virtual memory could
map to an arbitrary byte
in the physical memory.
Then we would basically have to
have a huge table of mappings and
we don't want to do that, because
that table would be very large and
consume a lot of our memory.
So instead,
the program's memory is divided
into equal size chunks called pages.
A typical page size is 4 kilobytes, so
this would be page 0 in this program,
page 1 in this program,
page 2, 3, 4, etc.
So pretty much the first 4
kilobytes will be page 0,
the next 4 kilobytes will be page 1 and
so on.
Note that each page is
aligned to the page size.
So the page, for
example is 4 kilobytes and
it begins at the 4 kilobyte boundary.
So this is our virtual memory.
Our physical memory is divided
into slots that can hold pages and
these slots are called frames.
So if you remember your caches,
pretty much the physical memory behaves
like a cache for the virtual memory in
that it has a certain number of
places where we can put pages.
So a page is kind of like a memory block
and the frame is kind of like a cache
line, except that this is the actual
memory we have and this is the memory
that the program just thinks it has,
but we never actually have that memory.
So now the operating
system creates a mapping,
where it decides which pages in
the program will map to which frames.
We can do something like this,
for example.
So page 0, for example, the operating
system decides to put it in frame 0.
Page 1 can be in frame 2,
page 2 can be in frame 3.
If we have another process,
it has its own page 0, page 1, etc.
And these pages might
map to different frames.
If we want this page 1 and this page
1 to be the same, because these
2 processors need to share memory,
then we can map them to the same frame.
And now when this processor writes to
its memory and this processor reads to
the same address, they actually
are accessing the same memory location.
So this process reads
what this process wrote.
But for page 0, for example,
they have different memory there.
So this process sees its own content for
page 0 and
this process sees its own content for
page 0.
So who decides how to do
this mapping here and here?
And the answer is the operating
system decides and
the actual mapping mechanism
is called a page table.
It's a table that says, for
each page in a process,
where is that page really
mapped in the physical memory?
This is the page table for this process.
Another process with its own idea of
virtual memory will have a different
page table that says, for
each page here, where does it go here.